hundreds of thousands of people took to
the streets this past weekend to protest
gun violence organizers of the
student-led march for our lives rallies
are calling it the start of a movement
and a wake-up call for Congress ahead of
this year's midterm elections it will
stay that way because they know what is
coming they know that if there is no
assault weapons ban passed then we will
vote them out the latest Fox News poll
found overwhelming support for specific
gun control measures including 91% of
voters who are in favor of universal
background checks on all gun buyers 72%
support raising the minimum age to buy a
gun to 21 and 60% favor banning assault
rifles and semi-automatic weapons when
the motion is adopted with the Congress
did include several reforms in its 1.3
trillion dollar spending bill last week
strengthening background checks and
providing funding for school safety
measures but activists argue those
measures aren't enough in Democrats are
hoping that frustration will help them
in November the activism of these young
people is actually changing the equation
gun control will be a complicated issue
for Democrats particularly in the Senate
where they're defending seats in states
like West Virginia North Dakota Missouri
and Indiana where there is strong
support for the Second Amendment they
have to be careful about embracing gun
control on a national level when they're
gonna be states and districts that are
not gonna go for that
retaking the house won't be easy for
Democrats either though the latest Fox
News poll found a tightening race and
voters candidate preference with 46
percent saying they'd back the
Democratic candidate in their district
compared to 41 for the Republican that
is a very different picture from October
though when Democrats were up by 15